[Applause]
have you ever traveled to Spain have you
ever visited Barcelona Madrid maybe the
Canary Islands well if you have I'm sure
there is something that might have
surprised you despite the fact that
Spain is in a crisis and as the second
highest unemployment rate in all of
Europe a wealthy country the cities are
clean the roads of brand-new pavements
there are international airports in
every other city and there's a
state-of-the-art high-speed train
network throughout most of the country
at least on the surface Madrid has no
reasons to be jealous of Zurich London
then again we're not talking about a
country that was at the edge of
bankruptcy not such a long time ago and
that now has gone through one of the
biggest political crises in their recent
history
the Spanish premier Mariano Rajoy will
have to leave the government Congress
has passed an impeachment bill
impeachment means that the Congress that
is the legislative power votes to kick
the executive out unlike other countries
like America insane you need to propose
an alternative government that will
substitute for the former this makes
impeachment attempts almost impossible
to pull off in this country but these
are strange days in Spanish political
life
brand-new Spanish presidents the Social
Democrat Pedro Sanchez has managed to
convince the radical left the
Nationalists right and the independent
Catalonian parties to vote against the
Conservative government of Mariano Rajoy
they will have one thing in common they
didn't want more of this
and now you might be wondering why did
Roy have so many haters well
while you might think it's corruption
and of course this is the official
reason but beyond the surface there's
way more there as we said before stain
is one of the most damaged countries
from the big financial crisis of 2008
and the former government likes to brag
about their economic achievements with
statements like this one
it has been an honor to leave this
country in better shape than I found it
Mariano ahoy this is why in today's
video we have a lot of questions to
cover first has been gotten over the
crisis already despite an economic
growth and unemployment reduction this
country still has more than a 16 percent
unemployment rate and other euro
countries like Ireland are growing
faster than stayin so can we really say
that they've left the financial crisis
behind and if so what credit because we
give to the Conservative government also
is it a good moment to invest in Spain
today we're going to answer all of these
questions but before we do let's take a
look back at the history men in black in
the year 2002 the eurozone was created
all of a sudden Spain Germany France and
many other countries started to use the
same currency the Euro and the same
interest rates the ones that the
European Central Bank fixes this seemed
to be a great idea having the same
currency a German bank and lends money
to a Spanish company on the same
conditions as they would a German
company but these advantages come with a
risk if Spain goes bankrupt this German
bank with Spanish debt might go bankrupt
too in other words if a country does
poorly they might spread the problems to
other countries
this is why when you join the euro you
must follow some rules one of them is
that no country can have a deficit
bigger than 3% this means they cannot
spend more than what they collect in
taxes this said let's fast-forward a
little in history to the year 2008 the
year of the international financial
crisis many European countries suffered
here Spain among them suddenly the
unemployment rate goes sky-high till it
surpassed to 20 percent this means that
all of a sudden the government collects
little money in taxes do you remember
those international airports and
high-speed trains I told you about well
they're certainly not cheap and this is
why was the inevitable happens Spain
Greece and Ireland had the highest
budget deficits in the EU in 2012 so
while the maximum deficit a euro country
could have was three percent Spain had
ten percent this meant nobody wanted to
lend money to their governments at the
end of the day how are you gonna pay it
back when you spend ten percent more
than what you collect if you followed
visual politics for a long time you
already know what happens when investors
don't trust your credit reliability
right and so what do they do well yep
exactly they ask for higher interest
rates now listen up in the eurozone we
have an index to measure the chances of
a country defaulting it's the so called
risk premium
[Music]
basically what they do is take the most
trustworthy debt bonds that exists in
Europe this is the German bond then they
compare the interest rate of the German
bonds with the interest rate of the
other ones the number that you get with
this comparison is called the risk
premium so in the year 2010 the Spanish
debt had a risk premium of 50 points and
this was okay but one year later it had
250 which is five times more Spanish
bonds at risk as containment gathers
force and this is where the men in black
came into the picture yes the men in
black was the name given by the
journalist to the european central bank
workers these ECB people went to the
most problematic countries in the
eurozone and to request it that they
follow the rules basically what they
said was it says right here that you
can't set the deficit bigger than 3% but
you're going crazy stop wasting money or
we'll punish you
[Music]
in countries like Ireland these men in
black were especially strict in some
like Italy they even forced the
Parliament to choose another Prime
Minister who is more fiscally
responsible but what a mad insane what
did these men in black do in the country
of sangria and paella
[Music]
but quiet man November the 20th 2011
this is the day when these Spanish
people's party kicks ass in the
elections the Conservative leader
Mariano Rajoy becomes one of the most
supported leaders in Europe only
surpassed by Viktor Orban in Hungary the
Spanish People's Party or as it's better
known PP got 53 percent of the seats in
Congress and they ruled in most of the
regional governments basically mr. Rafi
was so popular that he could have
probably gotten away with changing the
name of Spain to Rahul and so what was
this political programme during the
elections well basically I said to the
European Central Bank hey guys don't
worry I know my economics first gonna
reduce taxes and then I'm gonna make
loads of called business friendly
reforms that would make this country
like Silicon Valley
then those companies help people make
billions hire people and boom deficit
problem solves am i right guys
basically the whole hi campaign was
based on the idea of low taxes a mantra
for any problem was to reduce taxes and
everything los impuestos service
diferencia de todos los demás Kristin
Kaven a subir el partido Pilar quiere
Bazaar los impuestos para que todo can
be not part you know the what they say
during the electoral campaign is one
thing and what they do one day after
taking office is another thing entirely
so we have most of it this government
must raise some taxes for some time
during the first months of the
government raised all of the taxes
including VA t income tax and all the
special taxes on tobacco and gasoline
yep a conservative government made the
biggest tax increase in Spanish history
I'm all about all these wonderful
business regulations that would turn
Spain into the new Silicon Valley well
you can imagine what happens with that
one so what happens when you promise the
business friendly agenda and come up
with the opposite once you're in office
well voters they get angry but there's
nothing they can really do until the
next election but the international
investors they can give you their backs
the very moment you break that trust and
this is exactly what happened in Spain
Spanish economy in huge crisis after
credit downgrade basically the Spanish
debt bond fell under the category of
trash dream about that risk premium that
I told you about earlier so at some
point it went to the Satanic figure of
666 many Spanish banks were to the edge
of bankruptcy and no one wanted to buy
any Spanish debt staying it was at
collapse and that would mean no money to
pay doctors schoolteachers and tax
collectors only one team though only one
team could solve this problem and they
were black
Spain to accept rescue from Europe for
its ailing banks so what was this
bailout all about basically Europe would
lend money to lower interest rates
astonished banks could not go bankrupt
in exchange they requested the
government to cut its spending and here
is where mariano rajoy it is big badass
movement or as we like to call it raha
anomic s-- basically a once the european
central bank had already bailed out the
banks where i went to those men in black
and said what's up dude do you think you
could tell me what to do look at these
bad boys my theory was that Spain was
too big to fail so despite having the
worst credit rating you can imagine the
European Central Bank would eventually
buy all the dead bonds without asking to
any interest rate how well printing
money with this money Spain could keep
being as it was without making any
costly reforms but well now the question
is why would the ECB accept all of this
that's actually easy because Spain has
the fourth biggest economy in Europe and
nobody's gonna let it fail so the months
well they kept passing unemployment kept
growing and so did that risk premium the
Conservative government of the People's
Party far from making business friendly
reforms they did the opposite
talk about an example prior to them the
professional services like taxi drivers
were going to be liberalized but in
Spain taxi driver associations are
well-connected with the Conservatives so
the right-wing passed a bill to protect
taxi drivers from competition this is
why many sharing economy companies like
uber and a B&B now have many many
restrictions in the Spanish market the
question is do you think there were
hoist challenge to the European Central
Bank worked the answer is oh yeah the
ECB is ready to do whatever it takes to
preserve the euro and believe me it will
be
[Music]
SuperMario comes to the rescue
for months the ECB president mario
draghi said that he would not compromise
with spain basically ohio wanted him to
print more money so he could buy spanish
debt in other words rahoy wanted the
wealthier euro countries like Germany
and Finland to give money to stayin at
no political cost just because
apparently reasons very fair does it
well sometimes three out here's life's
not fair and ROI he was right Spain was
too big to think ECB could be ready to
buy weak Italian Spanish bonds since
then 25% of the Spanish debt is in ECB
hands and those words from Mario Draghi
saying he would do whatever it takes to
save the euro like magic one day at a
time the risk premium of Spain started
falling investors started buying debt
bonds because they knew they had the
backing of the ECB and this is how Spain
could keep piling on more and more debt
this country now has a debt that
represents more than a hundred percent
of their entire GDP meanwhile the rest
of the European countries have started
growing
since 2012 Germany has become the
biggest export powerhouse in the entire
world China has gone from being the
world's factory to developing a brand's
new consumer market where everybody you
can sell their products in other words
every European country is growing now
and that of course does include Spain
nonetheless
this is good news so every government
likes good news Spain has got over the
crisis in record time
this is already 2015 in this yes Spain
at elections again and the government
decides to celebrate the end of the
crisis with a tax cut in the middle of
the electoral campaign you raise taxes
the beginning of one election and then
one year before the next election you
put them where they used to be after the
elections again oil raises taxes again
in 2017 the government will have to cut
15 billion in its deficit as you can
imagine raising and reducing taxes
depending on when you have elections is
not the best policy if you want to
attract foreign investors and red tape
that's almost the same if not more
prevalent than before and if you
consider all the territorial problems
you'll understand why the unemployment
rate in Spain is still a 16%
other countries in the Eurozone like
Estonia and islands which had really bad
recessions are now way better than ten
years ago while Spain remains about the
same
so now it's your turn do you think that
the brand-new Spanish government can do
any worse than the previous one do you
think Spain has solved its crisis or do
you think there's lots of work still to
do there well please leave your answer
in the comments section below and also
visit our friends from the Ricans in the
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine and
as always don't forget to support us on
patreon where you'll gain exclusive
access to a lot of content and many
wonderful gifts if you like this video
also give it a thumbs up as always I'll
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and here even
more of my lovely voice you can join us
at reconsider media cast at reconsider
mediacom slash podcast severe
[Music]